[Music]
foreign
there are different ways to make films
that have CG characters what we're
interested in with performance capture
is the totality of the Performance
Physical emotional facial the eyes
everything the actor creates the emotion
the actor creates the moment it's our
job to make sure that everything the
actor did is preserved in their CG
character you are very hard on them
thank you
I'm the father it's my job everything
that Jake Sully as a navi does Sam has
done
I thought we lost them
[Music]
you can capture the emotion you can
capture the subtleties the nuances of
the movements you can capture the eye
and capture the ticks everything capture
it all I'll be nice once
then I won't
the moment I saw her for the first time
I was just like you're just so beautiful
blue has never looked more beautiful
the amazing thing is that the technology
gives me that portal to bring my 14 year
old self to play this girl avatars only
go around
in making a movie set on Pandora
doesn't exist avatars don't exist at
nine foot tall we have actors working in
a volume with markers on their body
facial head rigs on their head and we
capture a hundred percent of their
performance in the digital world at the
beginning of the day the first thing we
do is get into the performance capture
suit and that is a skin tight two-piece
and it's totally filled with ping
pong-like pools around us so they can
then track my arm and then translate
that into the virtual world they have
all these little cameras that send these
little rays which give an image of you
moving around so every little movement
is your movement and then we put a head
rig on and it's a helmet and it has a
camera that's right in front of your
face one of the big advances that we've
made technologically on the sequels is
the facial performance capture we're
capturing a much higher Fidelity of
performance I know one thing
[Music]
this family is our Fortress
I've done a lot of green screen I've
done a lot of blue screen but never
anything of course like this where there
really is no screen you're just acting
in a space no you must stand
cells I've always thought that being in
the volume is about playing and
Imagination and there is no kind of fear
or no shame you can do whatever you need
to do to get to that truth saving their
lives that's all that matters I have had
to work completely differently than I
ever have before and it's been an
amazing experience to go back in time
why am I different
[Music]
it is just remarkable to be able to see
the movements and the performance go
straight into the character and it's
like there's Kate and hey there's
Renault so that has been fascinating to
me
what is this done away
no what is this
I find as a director I'm much more
attuned to the actors because that's all
I have to worry about I'm not distracted
by the camera move or the extras in the
background I'm just there for them
that's all I care about that's all I'm
watching it's an amazing process it's
also the only way to do it it's the only
way to make this film
Kitty hey hey Kitty
Kitty
are you okay
I was doing that thing again wasn't I
yeah you were I remember having lunch
with Jim he started to talk about this
kind of forest girl who had a special
gift of connection with living things
and she's going to be about 14 and you
and I know how immature you are so I
think you can handle this
I said Thank you when you see Sigourney
play a character a quarter of her actual
age flawlessly she steeped herself in
the ways of teen girls hi Mom but
unconsciously she just became younger
and it was crazy to observe why did I
just be like everyone else oh
I don't think any of us are very far
away from our 14 year old selves it's
such a strong memory how great it was
and how awful it was and I just sort of
fell in love with the character Jim has
this amazing ability to write straight
into the heart of a character why am I
different performance capture gives
actors the opportunity to play
characters that they could not otherwise
play and Kyrie's character and
sigourney's performance are the perfect
example of that given by one of the
great actresses of our time
they took him I have had to work
completely differently than I ever have
before because you do have to strive
away all of that Sigourney Weaver
whoever that is and it's been an amazing
experience to go back in time and be
with that person every day she clicks
into the character that she is and it's
like talking to a 14 year old I find it
fascinating that she can Channel this
young girl whatever it is I'm enjoying
watching it so what is it was heartbeat
sound like
Mighty
she's marvelous to watch her it's such a
work of art you're watching like a
flower unfold and all of a sudden you do
not recognize that you are talking to a
woman that is 5 10.
that has walked the third for decades
and has made her Mark there so clearly
is mischievous little girl in Sigourney
she can be as imperious as you want she
can also be a complete knucklehead
it's a big Journey for her and for the
audience with her because it's okay
because she care about her she has a
luminous quality to see her playing a 14
year old kid it was magic it's what
acting is all about avatars only go
around
[Music]
foreign
we had a costume designer Deborah Scott
Academy Award winner I'd worked with
since Titanic she had to kind of have a
foot in both worlds because she had to
design all the costumes for the RDA but
she also had to have the whole other
half of her brain to design all the
costumes and jewelry and hair designs
and hair decoration and everything for
the Nabi costume design is one of the
most important parts of expressing a
character how a person dresses what
their clothes signify in a clan people
who perform different functions the
leader the fisherman a child that all
these people have a different place in
the clan
we researched indigenous people
literally worldwide the environment at
which the Clans live is extremely
important to what they wear
so the American are Forest people they
use things from the pandorian forest the
mankinda are much more adapted to water
you are not good divers maybe you could
have swinging through trees but one of
the main reasons that we've made the
garments to completion is the motion of
the Garment
cannot be understood without having the
whole piece so if something's heavy or
feathery or light or stringy or fringy
the way these things move in air
standing in a breeze underwater for sure
which is a huge part of the movie you
really have to have the sample to see
what happens to it I honestly believe
that being able to create the garments
in their full Glory as opposed to just a
piece of 2D conceived artwork is
changing the way that digital films will
be made every Fabric and every woven
piece or every braid and feather they
all have their own life to them they all
move in their own way and that's not
something you can get from just looking
at a piece of artwork and translating
that to a screen we work with water
digital on a constant basis even the
smallest thing like a necklace goes for
scanning where it can actually map it
they read the texture they read the
color and then they use all of that
information in a virtual world
believability that reality that we're
managing to bring to the movie is a
hundred percent gonna make it just more
real for everyone
[Music]
Pandora
a world of wonder
and mystery
from the Hallelujah mountains
to the endless rainforest
but there is so much more to this
spectacular and Mysterious World
The Cliffs of Pandora give way to a
mighty ocean
and a Tropical Haven teeming with life
over 50 Navi Clans live in the reefs the
largest is the Met kaina they live in
harmony with the Majestic tolkun the
fierce skim wing and the playful elude
beyond the great sea wall the akula lay
and wait
much like the rainforest every living
organism in this coastal biome has
bioluminescent qualities that set the
night a glow emitting light in
breathtaking patterns
all things are interconnected on Pandora
from the tiniest organisms to the
Towering tofu amidst the it's the beauty
of the ocean and the fierce terrain the
Magnificent creatures of the skies and
the sea foreign
I went to the studio and I said let's
not just do another movie let's wait for
the fences
I think what people are in store for is
Avatar that timed 100. it takes it to a
whole other place
I've never seen anything like this in a
movie
it picks up where it left off and he
just
my eyes weren't glued to the screen and
I can't wait for people to see that the
world is bigger the stakes are higher
this is our home I was always looking at
everything in wonder what Jimmy's trying
to create is very truthful very
emotional and grounded Tales
a family trying to survive
it's really got this level of magic and
crazy
it takes years to make these movies like
there's nothing like this
it was the experience of the first movie
but on steroids
[Music]
thank you